uh do you have an advice
that you would give to a young person
today
that would like to help you maybe
on the planetary science side discover
exoplanets
or maybe bigger picture just succeed in
life i do have some advice just to
succeed it's tough advice in a way
but it is to find something that you
love doing that you're also very good at
in some ways the stars have to align
because you've got to find that thing
you're good at or the range of things
and it actually has to overlap with
something that actually you love doing
every day
so it's not a tedious job that's the
best way to succeed
what were the signals that in your own
life
we're there to make you realize you're
good at something that you're
you're like what were you good at that
made you
uh pursue a phd and made you
pursue the search i mean that was the
one sentence version
in my case it was a long slog and there
were a lot of things i wasn't good at
initially
but so initially you know i was good at
high school math i was good at high
school science
i loved astronomy and i realized those
could all fit together
like the day i realized you could be an
astronomer for a job it has to be one of
my top days of my life
i didn't know that you could be that for
a job yeah i was good at all those
things
and although my dad wanted me to do
something more practical where he could
be guaranteed i could support myself was
another option
but initially i wasn't that good at
physics it was a slog to just get
through school and grad school is a very
very long time
but ultimately when faced with a choice
and i had the luxury of choosing
knowing that i was good at something and
also loved it it really carried me
through
you